The preparation process has just started after Yilmaz Erdogan...
...just offered me this phenomenal scenario, this phenomenal story,...
...which was telling about the miserable life of this poet.
And he just gave me one of the reviews, which of course belonged to Muzaffer Tayyip Uslu,...
...the character I was gonna act in the movie.
The reason he gave me that review was just because he wanted me to read,...
...he wanted me to describe and try to understand the sentence,...
...the vision of those poets, the sense of humor of those poets,...
...and try to find out some clues to make it real, to run for it,...
...to let my heart to bleed.
Go deep and deeper and deeper.
To find out some clues about these characters.